hey this week off fat man on Batman
we're gonna take you to Sundance and
show you things you've never seen before
all next on fat man on Batman
stirring what a stirring opening artwork
that was amazing burger amazing welcome
to fat man I'm Batman I'm Kevin Smith
mark Barnard hey so rather than leave
you with no show today we're gonna show
you the intro that I did for yoga hosers
up at Park City the Sundance for the
Sundance Film Festival the movie just
debuted last week and show you the Q&A
afterwards Jason Mewes shot both so we
got the content man we'll put anything
you are their type perspective take it
run with it now about that so without
further ado let me take you back put you
in the Wayback Machine with mr. Peabody
and that little boy Sherman and you can
go back in time to like last week and
change and see what happened to us at
Sundance a man is Kevin smelling I'm
here obviously at the Sundance Film
Festival parsley we are about to debut
show it I'm nervous as hell
nervous midnight is a kids movie what I
was thinking the audience was we can see
it at midnight but the audience is
packed the tickets have been going for
400 bucks on eBay and stuff so some
people wanted to see it well if you pay
for nine bucks or girl roses sorry but
I'm thrilled
I can't wait the girls been wonderful
all day we did press as a big group and
you know it's been their first Sundance
they've been alone this is my tenth
Sundance in 22 years by fourth as a
filmmaker as a director here with the
film two other times as a person one
time I was a judge here but this is the
this one special man because my kids
with me do the intro
I'm Road announcer stuff is it's been a
real weird trip for me so far I met
Trevor 22 years ago when he was if you
don't understand this is authorities
like you're all filmmakers dude like
Will Shakespeare play and years later
man he programmed the [ __ ] flick here
like I've watched so many people grow up
here not just myself this week here has
been so incredibly powerful as
sentimental nostalgic it's like going
back to high school at your alma mater
everywhere I look is a [ __ ] member I
want to see Bob Hawke doc this morning
and it was at the prospect where that's
where like we have chasing a nice
creative gathering some innovation I'm
screaming in the Egyptian our third
screening of this at work first got
bought at the past restaurants work
Harvey Weinstein sat down
remember to share story with you that I
like it was it was my Sundance kind of I
won I thought sure this will be kind of
too but I had a moment that afterwards I
was like I can't go home now why two
years ago when I came up here by the
clerk's me and Scott Mosier tiger
producer
we're gonna go to the directors bus that
a direct response to every era but
Sunday's little the Sun answer is
ordered
so we got a car we drove we couldn't
[ __ ] fine we got up there we walked
around there's a lot of ski lifts and
skiers and stuff but we didn't see any
director proxies of target we turned
around and we want to accomplish for a
Salt Lake City instead never went to the
judge brush I bet you moving here for x
to the fourth time to other times never
wonder the dirty but I got up the other
day and there's a very rushed on
Saturday and I was like no way I'm
trying to [ __ ] go like I've never
accomplished so I got up and I took the
drive beautiful gorgeous drive up
through nominees and I got up to some
engine and once again I couldn't find it
for about twenty minutes I was I got a
[ __ ] I'll go home and I was turning
around that's bail and somebody was like
sound Bobby took a picture of stuff in
the house years people were taking
pictures and right on as a self defense
and then one of them is kind enough to
go you looking for that Sundance thing
yeah where is it he goes it's just up
there so it's like 20 feet away where I
have been 22 [ __ ] years ago
we didn't go so there was and I saw a
desert London I saw people like so
Trevor Cooper people I saw since the
beginning my career people other
filmmakers as well room was packed and
so I got there just to talk to the
Redford speech now chair brother who's
giving the speech a thousand times over
there's life or variation of it talking
about in your film how important it is
and we're all filmmakers gathered in
this room and so they're not starts
piece and I go lean in the back of
Walkman is good here on the back you
take this picture and now he starts his
speech and I swear to God like it
[ __ ] hit me like a freight train
because he tells this very simple story
that turns out to be like the secret
origin of my life I didn't realize he
talks about like being an actor and
loving weird movies like did a ton of
film and he's like at that time there
was really no place for it no market for
and I always told myself I got a little
bit of success I would try to do
something about that
it's like years later I did get some
success in 1980 you started trying to
figure out how to do the film possible
personal us
in summons for a festival so he talked
about like you know I love the Native
American community and I believe just
like that if you take something out you
got to put something back
and so Sundance was my way of putting it
back it was with Bill in the community
for these people that made these movies
and he was one [ __ ] sentence shy of
going like some for the freaks
I've never there's no one else in my
life quite like that person all of my
fortunes everything that ever happened
to me in my career are predicated on
Robert Redford going like I think it
would be nice to put something back I
think it'd be nice if they had a
community I'd read about that [ __ ]
before the end of the internet and stuff
we could not find each other I dreamed
of being with other people who left me
and said yeah
none of this words how many total your
[ __ ] stories talk about whatever
that guy that happened in my life change
ever has anyone had more impact on my
life that I've never met I'm standing in
the room with what [ __ ] he finished his
speech he went out the door
I was just insanely so thank you guys
for bringing me back man but I want to
thank some of the people that will dive
into it so I was trying not to cry I
didn't do it so far when you're a
middle-aged very important to me because
in 1994 when we were here with clerks
me and my cruiser Scott Murphy came here
to watch the hudsucker proxy Cullen
brothers introducing and talking after
the hudsucker proxy now if anybody film
those catching the Koch brothers taught
me is like finding a [ __ ] unity I
thought there must be for themself on
the other guy I make a movie I can
either go I'm sorry let me explain
being there to ruin a focus young
filmmakers we were just [ __ ] thrilled
and [ __ ] like that and in that movie
there's an important lesson that like I
loved that when we took an end in the
moment but there's a lesson that I've
used my entire life that came right out
of this room so when I found out we're
screening here tonight I thought that's
amazing
came out of the movies very simple quote
out to the end don't want to spoil the
movie for you haven't seen the hudsucker
proxy [ __ ] you with twenty years ago he
comes down to the verse nine point
failure should never lead to despair for
despair looks only to the past in
business and in love the future is now I
felt so much in my career so much and
it's always led to something else man
I've stopped being afraid of a [ __ ]
failure for that reason failures just
success training that's it and you get
it wrong once I'll never get it wrong
again and stuff I'm here I'm at lesson
in this bucket from tonight you're not
going to learn anything like that man
this is this essentially yoga poseurs is
the movie but I would've wanted to see
your old girl
and when the made the movie about some
people on a shout out there he was a
very important me
things that I can to her and I was we
were working on this other thing
oddly enough of Krampus movies and I
said hey I've got this idea there's a
window to do it I want to build a whole
movie around these two girls kind of
like a girl Supergirl movie it says
there's a compliment people without the
combo and she went for it right away
she's no money so [ __ ] fast
two months after either that
conversation with her reproduction as a
miracle worker her Charles and that star
student without the mountain to do
anything there are full of sausages and
phallic symbols like them but oddly
enough is a very woman heavy movie
through the whole movie was produced and
made by women I'm like I'm a
writer-director that's it but these
three police no wonder that made the
movie man Liz Jordan
I heard anybody man in your creative
life surround yourself with women they
make life for a living so movies are
very important though this is that every
artist pickpockets the lines and the
people around them and stuff I pilfered
constantly I don't leave them very leave
very interesting like a fear based
creature so I always kind of look to
other people who do interesting things
my wife Jennifer for years has been that
person I constantly steal from her and
put it into my work I work wouldn't be
nearly as interesting if I wasn't
married to her preferred that been apart
of 17 years we got together she come
home from this thing called yoga and and
I feel like what you do there she does
upward dog okay so I'm the ten yoga
things and they're all in this [ __ ]
but the biggest facts of all hands down
to the two ladies at the center of the
movie they came out to scoop a little
scene in Jaws and because of this movie
made less sugar two years ago because of
that little scene this whole movie
exists and it happened very accidentally
partly I pulled Harley in success
because I want somebody to play the
convenience store clerk and I told my
wife let's put our leave the commune
store clerks let's be honest she's never
read a great job anyway I said this
would be our chance to see what
so hardly was in the scene with with
Johnny Depp and Harley and Lily have
known each other since in birth so when
I the night before shop scene or that
was like Lily's coming to watch us
tomorrow on set watch a sad and I was a
chameleon she goes across the line isn't
this fun to watch people act work on an
act if she's there let's just burn in
the flare so she really is prepared so I
hit up an athlete she's like totally ask
John I said Johnny an email we just
worked together that day we're gonna
work together the next day so many many
rows we've got said let's put her in the
same apartment still didn't get a
response and I needed one next I wanna
intercept and he was like hey man I got
your email and I was sorry
no he's going on I'm thinking about it
he's going I think if you're really
sweet I never imagined I would act with
my daughter's so like if we could still
do it as it possible to school our kids
out for the day said he realized
suddenly rehearsed together and we were
off and running there was honestly the
greatest day of my life is a filmmaker
of standing on a set making weird weird
is the stupidest [ __ ] movie ever made
as [ __ ] like that was one of the
greatest actors on the planet and my kid
was in the seat with like her best
friend alpha chocolate and it was
wondering that we were four of us at a
camera the two girls behind the commune
struck down and then me and Johnny were
on the other side of the counter tip and
I'm directing my daughter and he's
directing his daughter and [ __ ] and then
my daughter stops listening to me and
starts
work for it was an action and the girls
have never done the hell out before
really acting before they were just like
magic oh I'm standing next to my wife a
little time watching it on the monitor
and I keep my balls wrapped on that mat
so I cut the rest of the movie together
but that scene could not have these
great Caesar with Johnny Depp and with
Justin this walrus American stuff I was
transfixed by the courtesy I watched all
the time
anyone who came into my office said they
would watch this I'd show it to Jan my
wife constantly so much so that when she
said I'm tired of this movie [ __ ]
doesn't you sound like it but finally
one day you know just it's Jenny yet
again she's like why do you keep watch
this like I don't know I love this scene
so much is it what is it is it because
they're wearing like these smocks that
look like on features that I like the
way they look or is it because like in
the movie they look at their phones they
look up say shitty things look back in
their phones that's all she does all day
anyway what is it what do I like about
this and Jennifer goes oh god Kevin
you're so [ __ ] stupid you can't see
it it's two people standing behind a
[ __ ] convenience store now think oh
god you're right
throw
everybody's a Taoist authority to take
with you to your life I love that picked
it up from the the dowel poop when I was
a kid over that boat Essex TV's not get
on down and then suppose very very
particularly meaningful for me tonight
because to be greatest to go on to go on
us to go far to go of ours to return
an explanation
yeah I was just curious he said that
writing about two dudes talking is your
wheelhouse this stretch you a little bit
to do literally the opposite it did yeah
riding for two girls was ugly not very
easy for me I'm so in touch with my
feminine side I got man moves and [ __ ]
so I I can get into that headspace where
the girls were absolutely the most
effective weapon in that war I couldn't
I can't like pretend to think like that
like a queen a teen girl I couldn't
direct the girls to like this is a yak
bring a teenager like they knew how to
do that themselves so they're kind of
like they bring it all to life you know
some of the dialogue was made better by
then coming on board just kind of making
it real it's a lot of dialogue in the
strap sounded like a 45 year old writing
for 215 in the x-ray so I think it's a
stretch a little bit
I'm a name - why ladies the music is
that gonna be available because I need
to wake up to that every morning
yeah yeah I saw the possum yeah it's one
thing one screen
yeah we made to us like I showed up to
set he'd ask the night before he's like
a great makeup artist my god Joel
heartily there's no makeup I was going
out of course so we showed up to the set
first a shoot them and I ones whose
childhood they like he wants to see they
were like that John mr. death wants to
see us like Johnny's dad is you doors
that come in I came in and he's wearing
that knows that you seen moves for some
time started big pathetic [ __ ] nose
all the way it's my holy [ __ ] man what
the [ __ ] look at that is I think you're
overthinking this way too much like you
could have owned this one hand man
literally took all we would have shut
the [ __ ] phone
that kind of spirit led to this like it
started originally as about kids that
encounter miniaturized Hitler clones and
I'm like oh my god it's amazing because
you can't they over and over we all know
there's one weapon killed at once in a
Lourdes bastard you come budget was that
be made so Jason knew that was gonna
play miniature hitman like I went to Jay
when friend and I was like dude I'm
gonna roll through you can play those
people will stop going there goes J&J
table will say something else
so the idea was like he would be
climbing all right he didn't help much
mountain stuff and did let's the
weirdest conversation ever navigation is
one day it was like how to know where he
goes
so I'm watching a lot of Hitler on
YouTube really can't speak the language
but I think I got it he's yelling I can
do that like just putting in our give
him a Hitler mustache and shrinking the
foot of the movie I don't know it just
didn't seem like it was part of what we
were trying to do the whole thing is a
true north trilogy as brother Canadian
monsters and went through all these
moment I felt like maybe the velum
should be there should be something to
it so I called a lot of persons or make
a fantasy bomb instead of like it'd just
be a miniature death we should do
something took some like some that's
German whatever reason what is you I was
like well I think journey I think a
black horse maybe can look like [ __ ]
tree bark or something and Kurtzman Bob
person was the guy who said he goes on a
journey I think the [ __ ] bratwurst I
said you're a [ __ ] cheese you
should've an event and then I draw Jason
Mewes as a Nazi bratwurst right now he's
a good amount and then he texted me a
picture of pretty much with the frosting
this is the Jason Jason hard time with
prosthetics like at one point like we
had done prosthetics for one of the
movies and freaks out we put it on this
is ten years after that so I think you
think you're getting Andalus I'm not
going to do it just as you just simply
gotta put on a bunch and they got across
though is there anything I need to we
wanted to shoot it one day put all the
stuff on him and then he couldn't
[ __ ] handle I think it's very
claustrophobic I can't do it I can't it
was really like freak out don't worry
about it dude it's [ __ ] like we have
like a solution I've never seen subsets
I was like [ __ ] Oh [ __ ] don't know
who's there don't [ __ ] worry about it
will cost somebody else to play to
Bronte and cipher stationary snaps it
was Ellie Joel Osment cause Ellie's in
the movie and he's the father across was
founded with prosperity so as a baby
happy with it
and I called health and I was like hey
man Jason can't play too LeBron see you
want to play the Brasi because [ __ ] yeah
that's it why he goes because then
people finally stop saying they look
what the sixth sense about
and so I guess I'll do it because I
don't have to scream through through the
makeups or an actor or actress to hear
any like do this do this so it's like
and then I've actually got a movie that
was never the plan today I've got to act
with the girls kind even though we were
never together but they put me in to see
so he can't be [ __ ] 40 figure this
movie out and dad writes movie about a
bunch of ballets running at his daughter
and she's killing them all
well I am I thought it was awesome
melancholy characters night I think
angry with Kevin that I would also love
to see like a really cool action with
teenage girls like I would have loved to
see that every eye will see an apple so
yeah I really gotta try to that aspect
of it and I was like weird sci-fi [ __ ] I
was like yeah it's cool it's weird that
I love weird stuff so I thought that
might be a part of it hi I was along for
the ride and then the broad sees him and
I had to reread that page about 14 and
wants to tusks and just kind of got to
see the personality that's the important
distinction this taste right now yeah
I'm in this weird phase of my life
making these weird obviously received
toffee not even wash Yoko's clearly have
a meter [ __ ] about the audience anymore
and recovering masturbatory film levels
what I mike and mike is this weird set
back to you
it's major mess with me oh yeah I'm not
ready Tufts for organs it's trip
everybody I wouldn't be prepared
we might have to go Mia stop smoking so
it takes off more like oh yeah this will
chessmen nazi brothers I was immediately
I didn't care what the hell it was about
I was so down he was filled with Kevin
and and then I read it and I was like ah
this makes complete sense until we got
it I am I'm weird I like I like really
awkward kind of offbeat kind of things
and I haven't seen suspects where they
really know what I was before you have
been prepared to but I was immediately
mouth I couldn't be happier with it
like thank God I like it
the first film I worked on with Kevin
was red state and then and so when I
read this I was like finally a family
really [ __ ] up this is almost fun an
idiot and Disney asked so I said sign me
up if you want to play the defrosted not
Siemens and absolutely
tell me yeah I would agree with this
it's a blast
when the Nazis and I was very touched
food you know reference the idea of like
a home for weird movies I mean like when
reading reading something because that's
really the exciting part is just how to
read it before what anything and how
rare that is cool I was watching the
movie because you know the Jews 22 years
be objective about and with these movies
he [ __ ] better like early my career I
was not some really good filmmaker so I
just take my real life change names and
shoot that stuff and so when I ran out
of real life because at a certain point
when I was 20 21 24 when I came up here
for Sundance that kind of stop to happen
in real life like I had a chance of
being a real interesting human being
without an entertainer today and so all
that material that came from real life
so when people would like criticized the
movies like Bristol and [ __ ] like
jump because they weren't talking about
movies to me they were talking about my
friends me the things that I've lived in
Chuck this [ __ ] never happened to me
like tossed in yogurt hoses and stuff so
people could come up to me and be like
this is the best movie I've ever seen
I'm like isn't it and they come up to me
like this worst piece of [ __ ] you
remember maybe I'm like isn't it just
[ __ ] film plays man so objectively I
was sitting in the back watching the
thing and you know it's like I think a
lot of it works and stuff like that but
at the end of the day I'm like it
doesn't look like anything I'm doing
anything else it's not like this movie
Sundance the proxies
career that's kind of what I'm most
interested in trying to [ __ ] do
something that somebody hasn't seen
before or stuff like that so I don't
know like when Redford set about
building a community like it's just so
refreshing to see something new where
the girls are represented like in a
powerful way and just I don't know there
seems to be a lot of the same in movie
theaters and stuff but I'm coming to
Sundance here and having like being able
to show this it's obviously pretty weird
but I
like we're going we're going to and
everything was the same but just mildly
a movie set like they had stores but I'd
recognize the name they all sounded
think up roots what's that right
they had cops but they were dressed in
red from horses instead of looting cars
we all spoke English but there was just
a little bit different and some of them
spoke French
they had these giant waterfalls you know
I suppose of Niagara Falls all of that
they kept my imaginations kid because
there's a wall full of stories about
Canadian Daredevils who put themselves
in the barrels and go over the falls and
[ __ ] die and so as a five-year-old my
Canada's the greatest place in the world
man
what a man
mr. Issa so I thought deeper and luckily
Ronald sctv bothered over Kensi this
movie does not exist without strange
Brutus be trying to shrink to a girl
play around and then after sctv of
course to grass this is my midlife
crisis you know exactly making weird
movies about Jenna that doesn't exist
but I do it because I love the cupcake
so much it was such a [ __ ] fan of the
idea of the cultural mosaic Canada is so
this was kind of a way to honor it some
Canadian so I don't see
oh did you feel like we were there I
totally didn't even though I wasn't see
all those [ __ ] famous people ah just
littered Park City is littered with
famous people I'll tell you right now
man is as nice they say very nice things
about me stuff I appreciate it so much
but I love actors and actresses man I
love anyone can tell the lie that tells
the truth and that's why I do the movies
like not because of my god something to
say and should obviously [ __ ] not I I
do it because I love being around actors
and actress is the closest thing you got
to witchcraft in this row some people
like [ __ ] you I'm a Wiccan okay that's
the closest okay my bad please don't put
a hex on us but like somebody standing
there and saying magic words and you
believe it like they're lying a [ __ ]
million lies a second or whatever the
[ __ ] just like about who they are where
they come from what the dog's name is
who they're in love with what dark
empire is chasing them all of it lies
and we forget we suspend our window of
just police belief and we just listen
and learn something about ourselves in
the process not weird that's the closest
thing the magic words we have man actors
and actresses [ __ ] wizards
I want to believe right me too yeah any
people like you're talking about the
yoga is theirs cast yes as a matter of
fact maybe not on this picture but in
all the other pictures as well I just
love being around actors and stuff like
that actors actresses so that was kind
of cool for me anyway that's all we got
for this week man come back on Wednesday
we're gonna give you so much [ __ ] new
news about [ __ ] you care about not my
[ __ ] and stuff like that but until
then here in the fat cave I'm Kevin
Smith come on Bernard --an come back
next week same fad time same fat channel
youtube.com slash Kevin Smith
hey man it's me Kevin Smith thanks for
watching do me a favor click that thing
below that says subscribe every time you
click that you save a baby kitten from
murder